and a little bit late already so I will
uh ask our vice chair please to lead us
in the Pledge of Allegiance
congratulations
and see the Republic for which it stands
one nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
thank you and welcome back to the
environment agriculture committee this
morning
we are going to discuss uh uh our six
bills that are uh retained bills and we
are not planning on executing anything
today but we do want to discuss uh what
our thoughts and
um
comments are on these uh on these six
bills
and I also wanted to go over a couple
other things that have come across my
path
so
good morning everybody and welcome back
hope you had a pleasant summer all five
days of it
so I've been dealing with a lot of water
in Acworth where we we have all
horrible uh measures of flooding going
on anyway
um
I would like to start off with
our first bill
HB 37
establishing a committee to study best
practices for companion animal groomers
and I would like to entertain any
comments about what we may or may not do
with this bill and your thoughts on it
if there's any particular
um
work that you feel needs to be done on
it or
whatever
representative Brouillard
thank you madam chair
uh so I believe that we're already over
permitted we're already over licensed uh
I think it should be up to the consumer
to let them see uh whoever they do so
choose to go to for their animal
grooming activity to say okay what what
makes this person qualified are they
certified have they gone to some sort of
Institute let them hear by you know Word
of Mouth ratings let them be the ones to
decide
um
the groomers expertise
okay thank you
yeah representative germano thank you
madam chair uh and with respect to my
colleagues comments that say this
committee doesn't necessarily have to
result in more permitting or regulations
one of the things we talked about was
that there might be a set of
recommendations for example or questions
about where policies needed to be posted
Etc so uh I it's not a foregone
conclusion by any means that the result
of a study committee is going to be
excess permitting or anything like that
so uh whatever the outcome eventually is
uh I just want us to be clear about that
and personally I think from some of the
testimony we heard before uh that that
some of the things that even fall short
of any additional regulations or
permitting uh could potentially be
helpful to the industry and to uh and to
clients
oh representative Creighton
I agree that that other things could
come out of here other than licensure
however I would say that the committee
is not going to add any expertise that's
not already out there provided by the
AKC or other
agencies that
are private agencies that actually do
have the expertise so the committee
would be hearing from experts that are
already deeply involved in the situation
I don't think providing anything new
other than an additional committee that
we would have to be responsible for
representative Howard
thank you madam chair I
talking about
a question that representative Creighton
mentions so and along with information
about
um potential harms done by these
individuals or the this profession and
and
um like a collection of information
about how much how how frequently that
happens
anyone else
I'm sorry representative Murray I'm like
popping my eye in here uh thank you
madam chair um yeah I think also I'd
like to mention that we heard compelling
sort of testimony regarding some
situations that had Arisen as a result
of some experiences that
um resulted in sort of concern and
oversight around animal welfare and I do
think that it's important that uh the
charge does say that it's looking at a
few sort of areas so it's not a wide
open area
um it discusses safety and facility
standards possible certification and
life licensure and then
um waste and disposals so those are
things that even are very germane to
some of the other topics we discuss in
the committee
um
and maybe as representative germana said
other types of recommendations may come
out of it as a result
there you go thank you representative
thank you madam chair
um
having sat through listening to uh this
legislation for the last two terms
um it seems that it's the same people
and it's the same
um
person that keeps or people that keep
bringing this up and we have thousands
in the state and if you talk to
different people across the state in
this industry that are doing a great job
they don't want to see anything else
done they are perfectly happy they
regulate themselves word of mouth is one
of the most damaging things that can
happen to a pet groomer
representative knabb
thank you madam chair
um I just want to comment that the many
people I've mentioned this to have been
surprised that there isn't any sort of
Standards or practice around animal
grooming and
um I asked my dog groomer about it and
she said that some of the things that
were done in the situation where the dog
died they would never do so you know I
do agree that
um creating a permitting process is
probably overly cumbersome but I think
having just best practices out there
could be a good outcome of this
um without you know without requiring
licensure or permitting it would just
create standards that people adhere to
so thank you
anyone else
so for my own
um point of view on this is first of all
in terms of testimony we only had like
one or two people come this time as
opposed to previous terms we had five
the last time so it's not very
representative of of
um
you know the
groomer community
and the things that are being asked in
this bill to study
um
safety facility standards possible
certification licensure whatever waste
and chemical disposal education
continuing education
I have spoken to members of different
animal groups the AKC dogs
um various organizations who already
have standards in place for their
members that their members follow
and I would think that that would be
sufficient for the community to pretty
much educate their own community and
police themselves
with that information
um as well as you know consumers who are
aware of whether their dog groomer is
certified through the AKC or certified
through some other organization so
it just seems to me to be redundant to
ask the house to have the House and
Senate the legislature to have a study
committee to do the work that these
organizations have already pretty much
done
um so for my
um for my purposes I I don't see any
need for this bill at all
representative Murray
thank you madam chair
um I'd like to maybe
respectfully if I can disagree because I
I would like to see that there I'm
trying to think about instances and
where there are folks in these
industries who may not be part of those
other organizations that you mentioned
and and also
um with the discussion of chemical and
waste disposal that's really the first
time in looking at that sort of niche of
of topic
um
that we really delved into this I I
agree that it has come up in past
legislation but as far as this bill and
that's the general topic but as far as
waste disposal and chemical disposure
best practices I would
I would like to see there are not at
least an opportunity to consider it
thank you representative Murray for
bringing that up because it seems to me
as I recall from my own and maybe
representative NAB can chime in on this
for my own
um knowledge of like local ordinances in
various municipalities they already have
something in their ordinances to to say
how um animal waste is handled and as
well as
any kind of chemical disposal too it
would seem to me that
municipalities already have that in
their in their codes
representative
thank you madam chair
if they're using any type of chemicals
as we all know the label is the law
and I am sure that all of these people
are reading the the label and it also
talks about how you are disposed of that
type of chemical
again the label is the law
so I don't think there's any additional
requirement needed uh regarding that
it's pretty straightforward
um
anyone else representative NAB
you very much I don't actually have an
answer to your question I'm sorry but I
think representative spoke to it
um I I recall and I might be wrong about
this that one of the outcomes we
discussed when we first discussed this
bill was standards that already existed
and putting them on the USDA or not the
USDA the department of agricultural
website using standards from the AKC or
a similar organization
um and just having those posted and is
that a potential outcome and something
we could direct if we decide not to move
forward with this bill I would have to
touch base again with commissioner
Jasper and find out
um if that's doable if they be willing
to do that
representative Bixby good morning good
morning so if we did if we uh decide
that uh having uh
having the department web page make
reference to uh standards that are
already out there that's something that
we could do by amending this bill rather
than by having a study committee
so oh so that's so if there's someone
who wants to take on that uh task then
on bring forward an amendment for when
we exec probably in late October then
um that would be that would be another
approach to this
okay
anyone else representative Potenza
I think that's a great idea if you just
spend two minutes in Google the best
practices are all there from the ASPCA
um
it's all so clear in being able to have
that information
just on a you know on Des website is I
think it's great and without having to
have a study Community all that so
um if nobody else will do that amendment
I will I I think that information is key
so I think and there's tons of it that
would not necessarily that would not be
on the Des website that would be on the
Department of Agriculture oh yeah I mean
Department of Agriculture sorry
yeah
all right representative germana
thank you madam chair I I would just
like to add that I think that there is
an understandable philosophical
difference among some of us about how
the free market functions and and how to
what extent the free market can be
expected to regulate itself and the
extent to which we say that any business
interest or industry should Simply Be
regulating itself and when we're talking
about communities of various sizes
communities that may not have more than
one or maybe two I don't know we'd have
to look at it right uh facilities that
offer these kinds of services your your
choices are limited right and we're also
talking about a variety of price ranges
and people who can afford uh to pay a
higher price for services or more likely
I would assume to get a quality of care
that may not be available I'm not
presuming to to prejudge that but may
not be available at places where you
don't have
um uh where the the price for the
services is lower so uh I I wanted to to
add that act as a is something for us to
think about as well right when we're not
saying that this applies to the vast
majority of of uh places that offer
these services but if these concerns
exist for even a percentage of that it's
still a significant number of pets and
granite Staters who are affected and and
as I said I think it's entirely Goodwill
in their philosophical differences as I
said about the faith that some of us
have that the free market is simply
going to regulate itself on uh behalf of
the interests of people
and pets
okay
all right I think we've kind of
put that uh
all those ideas together and uh we can
move forward to the next bill if that is
uh okay with everybody
so um
so so you would you would work on doing
an amendment for that bill no
bring thank you
all right
um moving on to hb122
relative to micro Enterprise home
kitchen operations
I believe representative comtwa would
like to speak to this
yes thank you madam chair
um I would like to have the opportunity
to bring forth an amendment uh because
some of the information already
in this bill has already been passed uh
expect you know especially where it
talks about maximum gross sales we've
actually eliminated that dollar amount
so there do need to be some changes in
there and I would really like to have an
opportunity to present an amendment to
the committee in the next few weeks if
possible
anyone else have any comments on that
okay
representative Creighton and just just a
question and so exactly what would you
be looking to that Amendment what would
it look like
um I'm looking at an amendment
um and I went to Montana and to look at
micros Enterprise home kitchen
operations where a person could sell to
an informed and the key word there is an
informed and consumer uh any product
without labeling or package you know and
that way
we could have mitigated what happened up
in Meredith where they had the cease and
desist
um with regards to donating food to help
people that didn't have any means of
buying their own
okay
any other discussion on this
representative Murray uh yeah um the
um
[Music]
knowing that the particular details of
what are what transpired fully up in uh
Meredith like you mentioned I do know
that like the Good Samaritan act like
does cover certain donations and so to
that end I also am curious about what
the definition of informed consumer
would be and so how would you determine
what
consumer would be
um I don't have the definition in front
of me but in an informed end consumer
would be a person that is aware that the
person selling the product is not
licensed
that the kitchen has not been inspected
and that they're buying it
um with conversation with the person
selling that product what's in it and
have a conversation they would be
completely informed and they would have
the option to choose whether to buy or
not to buy
foreign
Murray uh thank you madam chair follow
up if I may sure okay thank you
um to that end is there um have you
talked with anybody in like sort of the
legal end of things like informed
consumer could mean many things and in
the event that
um some sort of harm or damage would
happen as a result of an uninspected
product
um what
what could happen uh if there was
serious illness or some other thing that
that's something that
would be considered in the potential
legislation representative you may reply
thank you madam chair and I apologize
for not raising my hair no worries
um
we already have legislation not using
the word informed and consumer but we
have legislation where you can have a
homestead license that is uninspected
the difference is is that you have to
have a label on it we have raw milk
products that are from uninspected
facilities you just have to have a note
saying that it is from an uninspected
facility
so we already have a precedence
for this in statute
okay
representative good morning good morning
thank you madam chair okay I'm going to
have my ignorance on display here
um because I don't know a lot about this
area but for example the other day
one of our colleagues was you know
selling
um honey out of the back of his truck I
bought it didn't even think about it it
was fine so I'm I'm assuming that we
have a a lot of people who do backyard
things and maybe they make you know 20
or 30 Jam things
um how is that regulated now is it not
regulated
um how do we handle it in law
representative Compton
thank you madam chair
so
as we heard in previous testimony and
the reason we eliminated the gross sales
dollar amount from DHHS was that they
don't inspect or regulate it at all
so that is the short answer
representative Murray uh thank you madam
chair at one point of clarification
um I do believe that there is within
DHHS and Homestead licensure there are
certain products that can and cannot be
produced to be under Homestead licensure
and it depends on uh bacteria certain
things that may or may not grow in them
and there is a list of products
representative thank you madam chair
that is absolutely correct this would
not fall under the homestead licensure
Act
representative Bixby you had your hand
up yes
uh I just wanted to point out that um
on page three of the bill that we have
in front of us uh the current definition
is actually there a homestead food
operation means
what it struck out a person who produces
Homestead food products excluding
excluding potentially hazardous food
only in the home kitchen of that
person's primary residence so
um the current uh exam the car the
things that you're currently able to uh
produce on that using that homestead
exemption are things that you produce
exclusively in your home and it has to
and it can't be potentially hazardous
food and there is a definition of
potentially hazardous food on the uh the
um on the HHS web uh website that um
that but essentially uh
jams and jellies honey maple syrup uh
all fall under the non-hazardous
category
um things that are fermented like
pickles are not considered uh are not
allowed in the
um in the non-hazardous anything that is
dairy is is an animal product other than
I think uh fresh eggs are would be
considered on not part of the that
exemption uh so uh there are
um and you can uh so there basically
anything that has the potential of uh
going bad quickly would be considered a
potentially hazardous food
and so you can and there's no there's no
regulation if you are selling jams and
jellies and that sort of thing other
than other than I think there are I
think there is a labeling requirement
but beyond that uh beyond that uh it is
there's a fair amount of freedom in that
regard already
all right well thank you
so I I suppose
with any of these retained bills
um if anybody is working on an amendment
to them
within the next couple of weeks I would
expect that the amendment would be
drafted and shared with the committee so
that we would have all the information
needed when we come back to do the exec
on these bills
and also to recognize that um if the
bill
is passed through the committee with an
amendment and it goes to the house floor
there's still a vote that has to happen
with that and then it would go on to the
Senate as well so you know
we have to still be mindful of the
procedure for for how this is going to
go ahead
any other comment on this particular
bill
no
seeing none
let's move on to our next bill
HB 326 prohibiting the use of second
generation anticoagulant rodenticides
and I would particularly draw your
attention to
a preliminary report that was sent to us
from the pesticide review board
which it was sent electronically I do
have a hard copy here with me and we
have the pleasure of Mr Rousseau joining
us today if we have any questions for Mr
Russo from the pesticide review board I
would encourage
um your questions as a result of the
preliminary report and with respect to
the language in this bill so who would
like to start off the conversation
representative Bixby
yeah so
um having read through the uh the
preliminary report
um I've uh was looking at the
recommendations in section e on page 10.
I think we all have this in on our in
front of us so if you want to take a
look at that
um
one so uh one of the the second
recommendation on that list is consider
product label revision to identify
state-specific restriction of second
generation anticoagulant regenicide
contingent on epa's final decision
for example certain pesticide label
instructions restrict use in particular
States Beyond EPA requirements this may
be considered for second generation
anticoagulants and so
um that's that's essentially a follow-up
to uh
what's mentioned in the report which is
that the EPA is really looking into
creating uh restricted use category for
these products and uh
the so uh I think that the uh there's an
based on the epa's movement in that
direction based on what we heard in
testimony uh uh last spring and based on
the the information on in this report
that indicates that uh there are a
number of wildlife species in New
Hampshire that have been showing uh the
presence of uh these anti-anticoagulants
um insofar as they can be tested and
testing is testing Wildlife is is a very
is a much more challenging process than
testing uh testing farm animals so it's
much harder to get the data uh so
insofar as there is data it says that
this stuff is out there I think that it
would be a sensible approach to make
sure that the people who are using these
products know how to use them and uh
that so I would suggest that we
uh revive amend the bill to say that to
recommend to the uh pesticide control
board that they use their existing
rulemaking uh Power to make these uh
um restricted use in New Hampshire and
uh and if that you know if any if
Federal Regulations come down soon
enough to make that you know Superfluous
great uh but if the potential government
shutdown that they're talking about
happens in uh at the end of September
and we don't know how long that's going
to last because we know how things fail
to work sometimes in Washington then the
EPA may end up being very you know
substantially delayed in being able to
uh finalize this rule that they're
proposing so and I don't think that we
should continue to put our wildlife
Jeopardy during that period so I think
that we should as a as a step to protect
our state wildlife uh say we will we
will
make it restricted use in New Hampshire
and If the Fed when the if and when the
feds come down with their final rule we
will then make sure that our rules are
consistent with their rules
thank you representative Bixby my own
thoughts on this are
um
I haven't seen any reports for that that
actually show numbers or any kind of
definitive
um
statement that
that these
rodenticides
have absolutely
caused
a negative
um
circumstances with our Predator
population I mean I haven't seen that
there is a decrease of our Predator
population
directly tied or as a result of the use
of these pesticides
and
um I know that might be hard to obtain
that kind of data
but we have to look at the the fact that
if we are restricting use
then what that is doing is that is
pushing the homeowner to employ
Professional Services
to deal with a rat or mice mouse or
rodent problem that they may have in
their home in their Farm wherever
their business
um
and I have
I'm kind of torn with this because
um yeah it'll certainly don't want
people to be purchasing buckets of this
stuff and just tossing it wherever there
should be some not some education some
knowledge of of how to properly use
these substances
but by the same token
um
we're here um at least for me I'm I'm
thinking I'm only hearing anecdotal
evidence from rehabbers or or
um
Wildlife organizations
of certain instances where they've found
uh poison Predators so I'm kind of I'm
kind of mixed on this so representative
Murray
yeah thanks Madam chair um I do have
some questions that I think maybe you
all at the department could speak to so
certainly I invite you to the microphone
Mr Russo
one of the things that I'm curious about
is the Bobcat study that's listed
through SUNY SUNY I'm just that's is
that New York yeah okay so um I'm
curious about that data and and before
we get into that I also just wanted to
mention I think in the previous hearing
of my member my memory serves me
correctly we did talk about
um some concerns about some of these
things being widely available in large
quantities
um and um also available online in large
um and to which end I think
um there has to be some discussion I
think around the availability of some of
these products in um
to the general public in that amount and
I I think part of the discussion
was about how do we monitor that how
does that how is what oversight
mechanism would there be to potentially
limit that so the first part is with the
Bobcat study I'd like to talk touch on
that and then talk about maybe next
steps or other measures that we could
do for personal use purchasing
okay uh David Rousseau with New
Hampshire Department of Agriculture
markets and food in regard to the Bobcat
study and I'm one of of 10 of the folks
that were on task force and I know there
are other people here so if I miss
something I just want to make that point
and someone can fill in the gaps but the
um the Bobcat study was part of a a
study from New Hampshire University New
Hampshire Diagnostic lab and it was
actually to study distemper and wild
animals bobcat being one of them
um and they were able to wrap in a
couple other studies to that distemper
study and one of them was what is the
residue of rodenticides and wild animals
and so Trappers would provide the uh the
livers of these animals that they would
trap and that's really the only way you
can identify the um the rodenticide and
it's and it's uh lethal impact to an
animal so that's that's how that that
study I think that was a question and it
actually includes um
for more New York and New Hampshire
animals and yes there is residue in
Wildlife that that's not um that's a
question that is the answer is yes
um to what extent the impact is that
that's that's the question now and I
think that the reason why the task force
in its five months of of six months that
they put together eight meetings decided
to go into further study was to identify
try to identify the the actual impact to
Wildlife populations
um and I'm sorry I missed the second
part of the oh
cards whether it's online or in the
stores in the larger quantities that we
were hearing about in our previous
hearing and I guess my concern is um I
think we had conversation at that time
about
um
they're being concerned about the
ability to monitor that and so I I'm
when you when you talked about buckets
Madam chair I think of these things we
do know that they're out there for
purchase right now in those quantities
so I'm curious about your thoughts about
changes around that
certainly if the second generation
anticoagulant rodenticides are
restricted use that takes it out of the
hands of anyone that does not have a
license and I think you will see
an impact as far as availability to
general consumers
on the history of rodenticide regulation
in right around 2011 EPA
try to identify those products is only
available to folks that are um that
tried to get it out of the hand of the
general consumers clearly that isn't
working so someone could go to certain
websites
um even certain stores and and buy a
five gallon container of some of these
materials as far as how we watch that
I'm on it to that it's really you know
when you have a general use situation
where someone could just go in a store
and buy something or buy it online we
can't really track that very well if
it's restricted we can track it because
that licensed individual has to report
what they use in a given year how much
where they used it what the target
organism is so there's there's control
there
um representative Murray I know that
you know the other thing too is
um as a consumer of a pesticide service
I know that some of these pesticide
service companies
or animal rodent control companies I
should say are stepping away from using
some of these uh second generation
rodenticides they I've received a letter
from a company that I deal with saying
that you know they've had enough of
consumer
um feedback of people who don't want to
use these kinds of substances on their
properties that they are now stepping
away from the use of these they still
have them in their toolbox but they're
stepping away from them and suggesting
other means of rodent control so when I
think that there's also at play here
an element of
the market correcting the use or overuse
of some some of these substances and I
think that we should also be cognizant
of that kind of activity that's going on
just so just so we know representative
Howard
excuse me thank you madam chair
um I have a couple points to make as far
as anecdotal evidence goes um it might
it will probably have to suffice because
wild animals don't go to researchers to
die they're not penned in they so the
fact that they are are in the hands of
researchers at all means that there is a
significant or some impact and whether
or not it endangers the species is
that's that's too late right and I use
um uh
um paraquat as an example right now
we're dealing with um the possibility
that Parkinson's is caused by paraquat
um and they're using it in the fields
where you know
um workers from you know Farm Workers
are are being exposed to it now and
there's lawsuits that are pursuing I
just think that it's too late to wait
until the impact is so great that that
we're talking about you know like the
you know the reduction or the or the um
elimination of a species
thank you madam chair
um
so
a couple things
um I was at a meeting not too long ago
where they said that the Bobcat
population was on the Rise
um and that there was
started they were starting to see a lot
of roadkill and uh Bobcats
so
um just wanted to put that out there the
other thing is is the pesticide control
board did exactly what we asked them to
do
they went in they did the study they
looked at it
I do not think that it is this jobs this
committee's job or the legislator's job
to tell the pesticide control board
which pesticides should be restricted
use and which should not I believe it
sets the slippery slope in the future
I believe we rely on the experts
and usually when we make a suggestion to
them they listen to us
the other thing is is rodent
problem
is on the rise in agriculture
I went to a greenhouse a couple years
ago never saw a rat in my life in New
Hampshire and they were running rampant
all of a sudden
people need
to be able to correct these problems and
it's not through a pesticide service
that's going to handle it
in large areas
rodents carry disease
and they affect agriculture in a bad way
so we have to be mindful of that also
and I do believe that the pesticide
control board will listen to whatever
we're saying here it will go back to
them I'm
going to make an assumption director
Russo but I am sure that you will bring
everything that we've talked to back to
them in our concerns
but I also think it's not our place
represent Bixby
uh the question for the director uh so
um
if this is a restricted dues a farmer
who has a pesticide license would be
able to use it correct that's correct
okay thank you
representative Creighton
representative see I'm sorry I didn't
see you over there that's okay thank you
um I was surprised to learn on page nine
the second paragraph uh when we heard
this bill first I mean the the
discussion was all about the increase in
rats and how it was affecting the
general population and I was really
surprised it says the type of rodents
noted included the house mouse and the
house mouse was identified as the most
common request for control followed by
the Norway rat
can you educate me I mean you know I I
have cats and every once in a while I
see a dead mouse
um and you know
I I just don't understand is are mice
how devastating our mice to Children
homeowners agriculture because I'm
unaware of that problem
if if it's okay I think it'd be best if
this question was answered by Mr Karachi
actually oversaw this study and if
that's okay
um I think Adam if you're all right with
that I can
thanks
good morning Mr Karachi and welcome good
morning uh Madame Karachi I own pastend
I was the uh structural pest control
person on the board so to answer your
question it really depends obviously you
get the occasional mouse that you your
cat catches not a big deal what we see a
lot of especially in multi-family
housing or low-income housing is the
problem persists and then you get into
attic spaces or you get into basements
and the amount of rodent droppings and
urine that is inside of the insulation
or in those areas causes asthma health
hazards other problems so it's not
necessarily the occasional Mouse it's
the situation where they they don't take
care of the problem whether that's on
their own or hiring someone they don't
think it's a big deal and all of a
sudden that one to two mice becomes 40
50 100 mice and a pretty quick amount of
time and then that can cause a lot of
health hazards more so for children than
anything else and then on top of that if
they go to clean it up you can get
antivirus you can get other respiratory
issues that can come from from the
droppings in urine as well
represent Creighton
uh thank you madam chair uh Mr Russo
just a question on the on the
recommendations what What legislation
would you need to enact these
recommendations
is there anything that you would need
from us
to to move forward with with the
recommendations from your study
if EPA moves ahead with their
preliminary decision which was to
restrict the second generation
anticoagulants there would be no need
for for legislation at the state level
okay thank you
and Mr Russo um director Rousseau would
you what's your sense of the time period
where the EPA would do this
when we ask we hear December of this
year
my experience is that sometimes it'll go
a little few months over that but uh but
that's what I've been told most likely
December
and as a follow-up what is your sense of
um do you believe that they would move
for restricting this yes substances I I
firmly believe that yeah
representative Murray
um thank you madam chair I get I guess
to that end if if we're concerned about
a timeline where there would be a period
of time where Second Use has not been
enacted by the EPA
um would it not make sense to put
something temporary in place that could
give us six months to a year
um where that could then be sunsetted
and it we could reevaluate where we're
at if that's the based on the study
results the information I'm a little bit
concerned that we don't have if there's
no data there's no problem and if we
can't
collect the data because second
generation General use is not tracked
um and we
had testimony as to the effects of of
these things and sort of we are seeing
the writing on the wall and where the
direction is going
um it it would be my preference to see
something at least temporary put in
place
representative Howard
thank you madam chair I also wonder what
the restrictions include and if we don't
need to use the EPA restrictions as a
Baseline and see if it includes things
like that they're mentioned in the
report like protective clothing and that
kind of stuff
representative Contour
thank you madam chair
if this product can be sold online in
other states that are local to us that
do not have restricted use
you're going to make criminals out of
law-abiding citizens because they will
go and get what they need
president germana
thank you madam chair I just uh wanted
to say that I agree with the point that
the chair made earlier very much so
about concern about you know the cost
burden right in terms of of kind of the
average you know Granite stator in terms
of dealing with these issues and the
expense of bringing in a pest control
person as opposed to being able to deal
with with some issues on their own
I would also say I was really impressed
when we heard testimony previously from
our Pest Control specialists in terms of
them describing you know the the kind of
hierarchy or right the the level of of
um
techniques that they use right and this
is kind of on the nuclear option end of
things and there are other things that
you would you would try first and I
think we all accept when it comes to the
application of these kinds of chemicals
that there's a line that has to be drawn
somewhere right so that we say that
there is a point where uh it should be
professionals who are doing this work as
opposed to an individual in their own
home and in their own community and it
seems to me that the uh the question
about making it restricted uh the second
recommendation I also agree with with
representative comptwa about the The
Pest Control Board here did exactly what
we asked them to do delivered a report
they gave us really valuable information
the second recommendation is that we
could do something right which is
contingent upon the outcome of the EPA
review right which means either if that
review takes longer than it should then
there is something in place or if there
are elements of that review that we're
just not satisfied with we could take a
different route
I would also if I may just quickly point
out I hope we don't ignore the first and
third recommendations we've been talking
a lot about the second recommendation
but this question about uh what kind of
evidence we have about the scope of this
problem
um uh is a difficulty in terms of how
we're able to gather the data as as
representative Howard pointed out and I
tend to believe in a case like this
where there's smoke there's fire if
there's enough anecdotal evidence it
points to something bigger than what's
here and I would really uh like to to to
see the development of what I see in the
first and third points because I think
that's our best chance of getting better
data so that we do have a better sense
of the scope of the problem
thank you sorry for the long-winded
and I I have a question for the director
is um
with regard to the recommendations that
are in this report are these
recommendations
that which you would have the pesticide
control board do in other words you
recommend the recommendation is for
the pesticide control board to explore
potential for further research
Etc
um
so the these um recommendations are
based on the 10 individuals that
represent um and that the list of folks
in their their uh yes affiliations are
are listed on the on page two so that
yes so these are recommendations that
were put forth by the task force
um certainly the board you know in the
board meets next Tuesday and we'll
review this by the way but um
and
determine you know what what piece is
the board could actually adopt as
recommendations
um
clearly it's identified as a concern the
second generation residue and Wildlife
so the board will probably
um and I can't speak fully on the board
I don't work for the I work for the
board I'm not on the board but um
the board could move to to sort of
identify that these three items be
addressed
okay
um but you wouldn't need any legislative
um
directive thank you
to to put a restriction on any of
you know any of these substances you
know you could do that on your own
correct I'm sorry I interrupted yeah
that's true okay
um
all right
any other representative Dotsy
uh yeah so just for clarification if we
wanted to move forward with this bill as
uh representative Bixby said and and
restricted
when we're looking at the time frame I
mean we could move this through and in
December if the EPA does
um
uh uh you know rule on this then the
bill doesn't have we can withdraw it it
doesn't have to go forward correct I
mean because it wouldn't go to committee
until sometime in January anyway correct
yeah right right oh okay so I mean we
could decide to move forward on it but
recognizing that if the timing coincides
it the bill could be withdrawn okay
and as I'm understanding the pesticide
control board can also say we're going
to restrict usage of this product
with this substance and we wouldn't have
to do anything
so um
represent Bixby
so another possibility is that we could
write the bill with uh an effective date
essentially essentially saying that if
the EPA has not acted by such and such a
date then
um then we direct the uh pesticide
control board to to make the
um
to make it restricted use so that uh and
then uh
that would also uh
sort of create and give give a little
bit more leeway and put a little bit
more power still in the hands of the
pesticide control board
representative Bixby I think that I I
I'm not um
I don't know that I would want to direct
the pesticide control board to restrict
something I think that's something that
we must leave up to them based on their
study and how you know what their review
board the pesticide review board decides
represent Bixby yeah so I proposed that
um that uh
uh I or someone else uh work on an
amendment and then when we come to exec
this at the end of October we can make a
decision at that point as a committee
because I think I think we're there are
clearly a couple of trains of thought
here uh and we're not going to get it
resolved today so uh we should
um so but it seems to me that we and I
didn't mean to interrupt you but it it
seems to me that we have two things we
were waiting for we're either waiting
for the EPA to come out with a decision
or the pesticide review board to come
out with a decision and I don't know
that
you need any legislative activity
to go along with any of those two
outcomes
well um and well I I propose that
um that I or someone else who is
interested in doing so make an amendment
and then we resolve it in uh when we
have time to exact because I don't think
we're going to get any further today
representative you have comment yes I
did thank you madam chair
although I understand Representatives
bixby's concerns and other members of
this delegation's concern this
committee's concern
we have a pesticide control board for a
reason we rely on their expertise
and again they have done everything that
we have asked
I think that delegate legislating what
they can and cannot restrict
sent is a slippery slope because what's
to stop in the future legislation from
bypassing the pestico control board
altogether
and and making further legislation on
what can be used in agriculture or in
the home or anywhere else
question
do you have any other comments
no but thank you very much for your time
on this subject it's greatly appreciated
thank you
all right
we will move on to our next
the next bill that and and thank you
very much uh I want to extend this
committee's thanks to the pesticide
review board for this very well written
preliminary report we look forward to
the final report
and we look forward to further
conversation with you regarding this
topic
thank you very much
okay
um the next bill that we're going to
discuss is HB 369
establishing a task force to provide
energy relief on farms representative
Bixby
so last last spring I spoke with uh the
Camel Valley who's the director of
Cooperative Extension to see if uh they
would be interested in uh in
um
and having a field specialist who would
help
farms uh
assess assess and and work out their
Energy Efficiency and uh generation
strategies uh in order to help Farms
negotiate the basically the paperwork
morass that this can turn into and
um
and he said that he would be interested
in uh having uh a position like that in
uh Cooperative Extension uh Cooperative
Extension has uh very good relationships
across the agricultural community in the
State uh so this would be a good uh way
to provide support a lot of farms could
really use uh to have uh better Energy
Efficiency and energy production
and I I don't think I need to go into
the details of you know how you know the
various ways that would be useful and
the capacities of farms to you know they
have the land they have the onto
um
and to use uh solar to uh uh for Maple
Farmers upgrading to
um to using more reverse osmosis that
sort of thing this is this is something
that Cooperative Extension could advise
on and
um I am happy to work on work with uh
Kendall Valley and uh and the department
to come up with an amendment to this
that changes it from a task force which
would just be a bunch of people talking
in you know talking in a room and not
getting much done to a field specialist
who would actually be able to
um help uh help move forward on energy
which is a an important
aspect of being able to run a farm
effectively
so um any
thoughts about that my I just also
wanted to interject that
um we I did send out an email late last
night for an email that I received from
uh
Griffin robers he's the state energy
program manager who made it made us
aware of the
USDA Federal funding programs rural
energy for America program reap
apparently that information is available
to small businesses and agricultural
producers for Energy Efficiency and
renewable energy projects so I'm
wondering if
there would be some overlap between what
our New Hampshire Department of energy
is already doing versus what UNH May
provide represent Bixby yeah so um I
actually spoke with so the reap program
is run through the USDA office in
Burlington which covers both New
Hampshire and uh and uh Vermont and uh
one and I spoke to people who have gone
through the that process and the reap
paperwork is uh it's real it's fairly
challenging and um so I got I got
information I got a list of from Tara
sad
um at uh Council of state governments I
got a
a list of you know what sorts of
information a farmer would need to
provide in order to apply for re for the
reef funding it's the sort of thing
where if you were a large
and the refunding is available to small
businesses small business according to
the state into the feds is anything
under oh 50 million dollars
so
if you are a 50 million dollar rural
business
then you can apply for this you can
afford to have your accountants figure
out all the details if you are a farmer
with half a dozen employees
you don't have it's much more
challenging I talked to couple House
Farm which did go ahead with applying
for a previous round of funding for for
solar stuff and uh and she said that
um
the uh that she had basic had to
basically cease all of her farming work
for two or three weeks in order to be
able to just figure out the paperwork uh
that's that's a burden that it would be
nice to be able to uh sort of relieve
the farmer of and to some extent so uh
one of the things that I think is would
be a real benefit of this of having a
specialist would be to have someone who
can help the farmers uh negotiate that
reap paperwork
oh and the other thing is I I uh
speaking with the USDA person uh she
said the USDA does not have uh the
capacity to assist Farmers with the
details however they do have a matching
grant program that would allow them to
cover some of the cost of a state
specialist if we did that
oh
representative come to off
thank you madam chair
every County
um
I can't assume but our County we give
money to UNH extension cooperative
and they're there to assist all people
in the county including Farmers with
grants and other things there's also a
non-profit agency called score that will
help anybody with anything and can help
with any grants
I don't think we need to add another
layer or another person
to help with this
we have a lot of non-profits out there
we have the New Hampshire Farm Bureau we
have UNH extension in each County we
have score and many others
I think that we need to
maybe get the information out to people
on what organizations are there
available to them instead of putting it
in another position
to do this
representative Murray you had your hand
up I did thank you madam chair I I am
Farmers already
time to do these applications and
representative Bixby is correct that
when the application process does go
forward in Vermont they can't answer any
of those technical questions at all they
are actually the person deciding whether
or not to Grant the
application to the applicant so if these
folks are then having to juggle their
farming practice or their production
side of whatever their value-added
product is without those resources we've
heard from folks like the Cooperative
Extension that yes they would love to be
able to help more easily facilitate
this process for Farmers they just don't
have enough of the funds or
infrastructure in place and this grant
program would offer that to or this
assistance would offer that
uh yes I was a member of score several
years ago for several years and
um I didn't I'm not sure that they have
different branches around the state
maybe maybe they do okay so there are
branches around the state and there are
uh farmers
that or people who would have expertise
in this area
okay because in you know I mean I was
only colleagues with a lot of Engineers
and and nobody was a farmer so I just
want clarification on that that you know
if if score does have that expertise
then they can be a resource
representative
um thank you madam chair I know that in
the Belknap area we have a great uh
chapter of score and some of them are in
the uh industry
representative Howard
um if we were to have someone who
specialized in just this process then um
they can they can serve a broader swath
of of farmers and and workers to get get
these grants um I work in I work in a
professional kitchen and you don't put
down one tool until you're finished with
that job you move on to the next tool
and I think that having uh having a a
position like this would give you a
sharp tool on that front
represent Bixby so
um
the way that Co-operative extension
Works uh deals with uh they're advising
through the county extensions is they
have uh they have field experts who are
uh who have different areas of expertise
in uh every County those sometimes but
sometimes some counties will not have
every single area of expertise so for
instance uh they're
um there are some counties that have
someone who is a forest specialist not
All Counties have that and they will the
the four Specialists will then be
essentially loaned to other counties for
that purpose uh and uh
um so for instance we have our
agricultural specialists in Stratford
county is a greenhouse specialist and he
will travel to other counties where
Greenhouse that need Greenhouse advising
in order to provide that surface so what
this bill would do is it would be create
a field specialist with an expertise in
energy there is not currently a field
specialist with an expertise in energy
and by creating effect by creating that
field specialist position that person
could serve every county in the state
and provide really uh you know the
provide this
um the knowledge that some specialist
can provide rather than a generalist
representative come to our and then
representative Morris thank you madam
chair and this is basically directed at
representative Bixby
um but UNH extension does not need the
legislator to direct what field
Specialties they have they could do that
on their own couldn't they
the the issue is with the funding so
um what this essentially what the
amendment that I'm proposing would
provide the funding for one field
specialist and uh I when I talked with
um director Lavallee he said that would
probably with the combination of salary
benefits and uh and Transportation uh it
would require it would be about a a
hundred thousand dollars
representative Morse
good morning good morning thank you
madam chair
um I'm just hearing that it sounds like
this is a recommendation by experts and
Specialists and so would it not be a
slippery slope if we don't listen to
them and create something that we need
anyone else yep
representative vote thank you madam
chair
um I will second uh what representative
Morris has said and I think when we have
one of the top research universities in
this state coming to us and we are
reaching out and saying we have an
opportunity here to as the environment
in agriculture committee for the State
of New Hampshire
to add to bring somebody in
from this top university to basically
assist Farmers with getting the
resources they need in order to be
successful
I will second that that thought and also
add that there definitely could be a
slippery slope with that because in the
public eye then it looks like wow the
environment and agriculture committee
had an opportunity to give Farmers the
necessary resources and then that did
not occur
that is all I'm elevating on that level
thank you madam chair representative
smart
um so I looked at that list this morning
quickly
I was having my coffee
and um I just went through and looked at
the one the businesses in my county that
I know about and we keep talking about
farmers and a lot of those businesses
are small businesses they're not farmers
um and they've received large sums of
money
I just and I I
um represented
Bixby said I don't know it was something
about businesses small businesses that
earn 50 million or less are allowed to
apply for this
um
I don't know is there a way that we can
limit and so that the farmers get first
dibs
um and that you can't I don't I don't
know how that works but it seems to me
that adding a a person to represent all
the counties is going to enlarge not
only the government but that that
department one person is going to say oh
I can't do all the counties and so
trying to it will increase that
department and
in turn increasing our taxes
so is there a way that we can
lower that amount use those funds and to
to support our farmers and and this
venture
in Bixby okay so uh the way that the the
way that the reap program which is the
uh basically rural energy program that
that is uh something that is through the
USDA and the USDA makes the rules and
their rules say this is for Rural
operations and any rural business or
Farm uh that is 50 million dollars or
under is qualified to apply for we can't
affect those rules but what we can do is
make our Farmers more competitive
competitive in the competition for those
funds by providing them with the
assistance to apply for them
representative smart
so the only way would be to raise more
money for more taxes to support our
small farmers that I mean I don't
I I see this as a vicious cycle not
helping anybody
representative
thank you madam chair basically what it
is is hiring someone to write a grant
so you're hiring a grant writer uh so
that farmers can apply
to this reap program
or any other program representative
Murray
um thank you madam chair that that was
my point I think that um to represent
based based on what representative Bixby
was saying I think that what we are
recognizing is that some of the other
Industries and businesses that he
mentioned with that income cap have have
a leg up on Farmers with the ability
um to hire somebody independently
um and go out and seek those grants
whereas Farmers don't necessarily A have
the time nor the extra funds I mean we
see that our Farmers sometimes are
living on very small budgets here in New
Hampshire and I think that this would be
an opportunity to present
um an additional Resource Bank for them
to be able to seek the grants know
what's out there and then be able to to
access those Okay so
I mean in a nutshell I think we're
looking to have
some mechanism program
agency organization whatever
dedicated to help our Farmers
know about
and as get gain assistance for these
energy programs
the question is does that
already exist
and I know in Sullivan County we just
hired a grant writer
and that grant writer is available for
anybody
to specifically municipalities in the
county but I would imagine if they
put out a you know an individual wanted
to get in touch with
whoever it is the the person that they
could pose a question I'm looking into
getting this kind of Grant or do you
know of any kind of grants for this so
I'm just wondering if if this is
um
if this is replicating anything that's
already existing and I and it sounds to
me that representative comtwa is saying
it is
as well as representative smart is
saying
um representative datsey your your
comments uh yeah I would you know you
know would say if I'm looking at
that we would not have any resources and
even though you think of Nashua and
Manchester and Merrimack as comprising
Hillsborough County we have a lot of
small farms in Milford and Wilton and
Goffstown and on and on and on and they
would have no resources because score
certainly would not be a resource for
them and you know and we our farmers in
Hillsborough County rely very heavily on
UNH extension so you know
for a hundred and ten thousand dollars a
year to hire somebody who would have not
only the grant writing expertise but the
energy expertise you know I think would
be a good use of funds the other thing
is is that you know our mission here is
to support agriculture okay and I think
if we can support farmers in in this way
it's certainly a good use of our mission
did we hear refresh my memory did we
hear testimony from the New Hampshire
Department of energy as to whether or
not they are in a position to help any
of our Farmers with that representative
Bixby yes they uh they said that they
did not have the capacity to do that
within within their Department within
their department so this is this is
basically they said that
um it's a program that they they're it's
a federal program that they are not uh
sort of qualified to
um provide the support for there are
there are scattered types of support
across the state you know some some uh
installers might provide this assistance
but what what what's lacking is having
one person that farmers can go to and
say
can you help me figure out what I can do
do to improve my uh my energy situation
on my farm and get advice and that and
the this this field specialist might not
do the grant writing on him or herself
they might say they might provide they
might say okay these are the solar
installers that might be able to help
you with that grant writing process
these are
uh these These are the federal funds
that might be available for you these
are State programs that might be
available for you uh these are different
aspects of energy on your farm that by
working on them together you could get a
more effective uh Energy System than by
just doing uh putting in solar panels
piecemeal and Farm Bureau can't provide
that Farm Bureau does not that's not
what Farm Bureau does from so
um but so what we're looking at is
someone who can really provide the uh
the advising expertise to help
farmers pull together the resources that
they need most efficiently and that is
something that
Cooperative Extension does highly
effectively in a number of different
fields I so for instance if the The
Cooperative Extension forestry expert
does not write the forest plant
management plan for a Timber owner they
say they provide the education to help
the far the timber owner
know how to select a uh Forest manager
uh so in by the same token this field
specialist would provide the farmer with
the
with the knowledge that they need in
order to pull together the re their the
resources as efficiently as possible and
another aspect of it is there is a lot
of federal money out there that New
Hampshire is missing out on because we
don't have the capacity the because
people don't know how to do this and
they don't know if it's available okay
representative
thank you madam chair
um representative Bixby you mentioned
installer and then you mentioned solar
so basically is this strictly uh when
you're talking about energy efficient
are you talking about solar installation
and if so
if it is solar most of these solar
people would know about all these grants
and would be more than happy to help the
farmer
not strictly for solar this is for the
entire range of energy uses on the farm
and how to uh
how to uh
basically optimize all those research
all the resources available so it's it's
not uh figuring out one Niche or another
Niche it is looking at looking at it as
a global or as a the holistic uh use of
energy on the farm and how to
uh maximize Energy Efficiency which is
not solar solar is Generation uh and
also maximize generation and figure out
um how you know what resources are
available uh and that's
having an expert who can provide that
education is something that is has
proved to be very valuable in different
aspects of agricultural and business
business planning operations uh using
the uh the extension model and I think
that it would be very effective to use
take advantage of that that extension
model to provide this service for the
state
thank you representative Bixby
representative Haskins
thank you madam chair good morning I'm a
little confused by this conversation
because I've been so impressed over the
course the learning curve of my first
term about the support for Family Farms
in New Hampshire this looks to me like
an opportunity to embrace something
that's going to help our farmers and the
department has said they can't do it so
let's get somebody who will do it
thank you
well I think just healthy
conversation and about various aspects
of how and why this should happen and if
it should happen and if there's any
overlap between other departments Etc is
is a good conversation to have so that
we're not
making decisions that you know may have
an unintended consequences or anything
else but
that just like to clarify that so
representative coulon
your thoughts
thank you madam chair yeah so I know we
have 4 000 small farms in the state so
I'm just curious is there data out there
that we know how many of these Farms are
interested in solar and how many you
know this person that we would bring on
how many you know people are they going
to be able to serve and uh just
particulars like that another concern
that I have is that it seems like
it's where we could be getting a little
loose with what is a farm and what is
like a small business so is this
you know assistance is this for anyone
that wants solar and you know any County
or I'm just
want to get straight on the details a
little bit yeah bring up a good a good
point representative colon represent
Bixby in your discussions with Mr
Lavalley and so and others
what is their sense of
um the
numbers of people they that they would
be able to handle with just one person
and would is there thought that they
might need more than one person to do
this uh and so
um the sense that I got from uh director
of the valley was that
um
one person would be one one full-time
person would be capable of doing this
and that uh in terms of the numbers
the numbers of uh people served and and
how that works
um
I know that Cooperative Extension has
very good numbers on uh how many people
their their field Specialists serve in
different areas in in different areas of
of specialty and uh
one of the things that I I don't I don't
have those numbers off the top of my
head but one of the things that I'm
always impressed with when I'm going to
my County
um working with the county
advisory committee for Cooperative
Extension is
how many contacts the various special
Specialists have with uh our New
Hampshire residents uh to help them work
on their
um
the the projects they need to work on
you know how many people how many Timber
owners the far the Forester helps with
how many
um how many businesses the business
development people work with they are
incredibly good at leveraging resources
and I think that which is one of the
reasons that I think that this could be
a real uh powerful assistance for our
our state's farmers and uh
the in terms of whether it would be
strictly Farmers or other rural
businesses that is you know uh I had I
had envisioned this as being essentially
for Farmers but that is something that
if we want to expand it to a certain
range of rural businesses in terms of
people who are sort of the support
businesses for Farmers like feed stores
Etc that I mean we could look at we
could look at that as a as a possible
approach to it on but
um I think that uh I'm just kind of
looking at the clock and thinking we'll
probably discuss this as much as we need
to discuss it right now and I will work
on bringing forward the amendment and uh
and we can have a more uh continue to do
the discussion when uh it's time to okay
fair enough I think we'll we'll just
have representative and then
representative Murray and uh wrap it up
thank you madam chair uh and thank you
representative coulin for bringing that
um to the Forefront and I would ask
representative Bixby in his Amendment
to focus on farmers and to identify put
in a definition
because
as representative coulon mentioned we
have over 4 300 Farms listed in in the
state
and we need to make sure that they are
the priority and not someone just in the
rural community regarding this program
thank you representative Murray thank
you madam chair I I also would like to
Echo representative kumtot and represent
coulon in their desire to have farming
well-defined I would also like to see
that including things like aquaculture
and other types of farming that are not
just traditional land use farming so
when we're talking about those things
I think the real in the realm of what's
possible here for New Hampshire and New
Hampshire farming having access to a
resource like this is incredibly
beneficial to not only the farmers
themselves but the state thank you
representative Potenza you are the last
person
to speak here
so just quick question for
representative Bixby so is this entire
Bill going to change and actually focus
on you know the whole gamut of energy
relief and not just solar and then
um in regards with this position that
you're talking about a field specialist
you know
um costs and all of that type of stuff
will be outlined because it as of right
now these people that are going to be
appointed from the commissioners
are just you know experts in the field
and all of that that are not being paid
so
this is a Bixby so the amendment will
completely rewrite the bill it will no
it will not be a task force it will not
be people appointed it will be it will
simply create a field specialist uh in
the in Cooperative Extension who will
focus on the entire focus on farms and
uh how Farms can
optimize their energy uh infrastructure
and uh the when I talked with director
of Valley last spring he said that the
cost of such a specialist would be a
hundred thousand dollars including
salary benefits and uh transportation
and I might add to that that we did uh I
did ask
um representative Weiler who is chair of
the finance committee whether or not
such funding would be available and he
enthusiastically said yes for sure
so
um with that being said I've also had
conversations with other colleagues of
mine who have said
you know we really give a lot of money
to UNH already and I'm surprised that
they can't find enough money in their
own budget to deal with this without
getting more that being said
um
I think I will be interested in seeing
the amendment that you you develop
representative Bixby and we can leave it
as that for now and come back and talk
about it
um when we when we look at the um
at the um the bills that
we're gonna dispose of
okay
thank you for very interesting Lively
conversation on all these bills this
morning it's very very nice I'm enjoying
this
um okay HB 493 eliminating the state
Meat Inspection program
representative Bixby uh this is my bill
I don't think it should go forward end
of discussion
short and sweet that's good anyone else
have a comment on this side and I agree
okay move on okay so our very last bill
that we're going to discuss is hb602
relative to landfill citing have we had
enough of this topic this year
uh representative Bixby
um I think that
um
we saw what happened with our other
landfill citing Bill uh and that I I
have heard that the Senate are Senate
counterparts have no interest in seeing
another landfill Bill uh I think that it
would not that there's not much use for
this one at this point
representative Potenza
so representative Simon I assumed was
going to be here today and he's not and
so
um just in championing for him uh
there is going to be Amendment that's
going to be put in I believe on 602
um and I can read I mean I can literally
read what it's going to do and it's
pretty much replacing everything that's
in here
and uh it's it's not going to be us like
in a sense a citing Bill and so
um
do you want me to do that or what would
you like well as far as I understand and
what my colleague representative Compton
is telling me that we are the only ones
who can put an amendment onto a bill
that we are considering that has been
retained that someone else in the house
can't change that bill
so that's true well then maybe I was in
Bixby yeah yeah so uh yes the
[Music]
an amendment on it then uh that is that
is entirely your right as a member of
the committee
and uh if you would like to just tell us
briefly what that Amendment would do
then um I think we'd be happy to hear
that
I'd be happy to
so
um my esteemed colleague patenza and I
are working on an amendment for this
bill
um we are extremely concerned about two
issues one is transparency
and the other is protection
so the essence of the amendment will be
for Des to have a process that allows
the public to to see what they are
coming up with that there would be in
the spirit of protection
some prohibitions to where citing a
landfill would be completely
inappropriate
so again protection and transparency and
public hearings public comment we're
just trying to ensure that the people
who will bear the burdens of the
decisions we make will have ample
opportunity for input will have enough
transparency to know what the process is
what under what's under consideration
and we'll work on the wording and get
back to you when we have it
okay
and I'd just like to say that I'm sorry
so
um
I think that this is a win-win
especially for Des and I think it for
the most part I'm gonna just read so
unlike other states
um New Hampshire's landfill application
process requires that the developer to
submit each permit air Wetland Solid
Waste in full before Des will review it
this can be very costly to developer and
to the state as thousands of persons
hours in staff time are needed to review
a full application therefore like a
two-phase permit process will save both
private and public money so this bill
merely asks Des while it's already
revising the relevant regulations to
create a preliminary application Phase
so that applications that are clearly
ill-conceived can be rejected based upon
evidence contained in partial permit
application those applications deemed
plausible can then proceed to a full
application which can be processed more
quickly than a single phase applications
since d es will already have evaluated
the basic parameters of the location
proposed so because Des already does
have this information there's there's
certain things that would be an
automatic reject which you know our
committee does know pretty well so so
that's just giving you a little bit of a
preview it seems to me though so that
you're you would be rewriting the entire
Bill why wouldn't you just submit a new
bill for next year
and scrap this one
[Music]
represent Bixby yeah
yeah
um I think that
um
because the and because what the
proposed amendment is would be doing is
in fact uh related to the the permitting
process uh I and I think this actually
uh this is actually a very reasonable
thing to do with this bill so I'm so I
think that
um in terms of why you would do why you
would do it uh amend this rather than uh
have it you know put submit a new bill
um
one aspect of that is that uh it gets it
gets us through the process a little bit
faster that's right so uh we can if if
we choose to to
um
to accept this amended bill in our
committee it goes to the floor in the
house in January instead of uh instead
of in February or March it then goes
immediately to the Senate so that it
will probably save three or four months
on the bill process and that's not crazy
no except that it would seemed to me
that since this is a whole rewrite
it hasn't really had a public hearing on
on the
new
the new aspects of this bill
that would be my only concern
representative Murray I'm sorry no thank
you madam chair
that there is a connection to the type
of
information that was brought forward
between the committee so representative
Bixby I think I mean I'm not opposed to
it I'm just questioning it
representative Potenza
so it's to me it's kind of like this
bill talks about what is is
um
the mandatory language
and instead we're kind of bringing it
back to the permissive language so
it's really the same bill but it's just
leaving the outcome of the agency rather
than like prejudging the outcome so it's
not totally different but it's just it's
instead of going down because they're
doing the rule making we're not giving
those criteria we're kind of dialing it
back a little bit so yes there's
difference I understand that but I I
still think it's within the same scope
that we can do this
represent Bixby I think
I think they're uh amending it to to
this extent would be considered
non-germaine we should consult with it
with uh the clerk about that and Paul
can give us a read on whether we might
need to have a new public hearing okay
thank you I would do that and so I would
look forward to seeing whatever
Amendment you come up with and then pass
it by the house clerk to see if it is uh
substantially different and require uh
you know call of whether it's germane or
not representative Howard
I have a question a question for the
writers of this amendment um does that
does this preclude
um the the criteria are we entrusting
the rules to the back to the commission
and um and not uh having any
requirements about the rules
or or the the criteria for citing
I'm sorry Linda has representative
Haskins thank you madam chair
um we're giving the department the kind
of guidance that we believe they need to
write the rules
so we're just going to we're going to
clarify there's there's not a lot that's
new it's just clarifying with language
that will help us
increase the protection for landfill
citing
representative Murray and then
I was just going to mention the same
thing as representative Murray that the
rule making process is already underway
and by the time we this gets to the
floor
um they'll already probably be nine
months to a year already in the
rulemaking process
thank you representative germanna
thank you madam chair uh I just want to
say I look forward to reading the uh um
the amendment I for one am not sick of
the landfill citing bills uh uh but one
of the things that I appreciate and as I
said I look forward to seeing the
details is that we focused a lot on on
the rules and with good reason but I I
think we do need to have a conversation
about the permitting process itself uh
that are there better ways both for
applicants and for Des to to operate
that permitting process so if it's a
staged process uh to take a look at how
other states for example conduct their
permitting processes so I I in
particular I look forward to reading the
amendment and and more detail about how
the the permitting stages would be
structured
thank you
okay so I just want to get a reading
from the committee here
um we've mentioned several bills today
that would be brought some new
amendments would be brought to them do
we want to have another work session to
review those amendments
um and discuss those and then have
another
um another meeting where we have our
actual exec session how does everybody
feel about that representing Bixby
I think another work session would
probably make sense yeah okay and
any uh sense of everybody as to what the
time frame for those
for the for that next meeting should be
do you uh do how much time will we need
for amendments to be uh drafted and
developed on Bixby I'd suggest early
October
okay early October we can have a
representative come tomorrow thank you
madam chair
um representative Bixby with OLS being
flooded with legisla you know
LSR requests this week will these bills
take priority
oh oh in terms of what so so so so the
uh with the amendment process as opposed
to the new bills for next term uh I
believe that uh certainly we don't want
to give them any amendments this week
so uh but
um but uh starting you know if we if we
have the amenities as starting next week
as soon as we have the Amendments
prepared to the point where uh we think
that they're ready to be drafted then uh
we
then we can bring them to OLS but I
think that it would it would not be uh
useful to have them going in this week
okay so um perhaps maybe what we can do
is uh have another work session on
October 24th
and then an exact session on the 31st
how does that how everybody feel about
that
or
um
you know
yeah
Madam chair can I just I I do believe
there was also a subcommittee that is
convening in October at some point so I
wanted to make sure that we weren't
right I wanted to go over that as well
um
the rules committee uh rule subcommittee
is meeting on the 24th
um
but we can work timing on that and
adjust it so we could do both meetings
same day if that's okay with everyone
else
I mean we can also
we can also do uh October 24th of a for
our next
um
work session and then do an exec session
on the seventh because I don't know if
people have children they want to go
Halloween trick-or-treating with and
whatnot I don't wanna
where's our deadline
it is an election day yes
uh yes I'm doing uh committee stuff on
on election days
all right well I guess we can do exec
sessions not going to take very long
anyway so if we did October 31st we
could just do that early in the morning
take care of the six bills and
representative Contour Madam chair
um I agree that we need another work
session
but do you think the work session will
take all day on the 24th and if not
could we just do the exact session in
the afternoon oh okay that works too
okay then we'll do that
thank you for that suggestion
representative Murray comment over here
yeah I just wanted to make sure show for
our own planning purposes if we choose
to condense all three meetings into one
day it would be the Rules meeting it
would be our work session and then the
exact that would be a full day correct
I'm saying you want to have a you're
going to want to have a caucus in
between they're they're I'm sorry man
charity
representative Murray's exactly right if
we did the rules
than the uh discussion and then the
exact you're probably just looking at
this they're going to be two or three
bills here we're going to want to have a
a caucus on so you add that in there and
lunch that's
you know just get ready get a good
night's sleep beforehand because that'll
be a long day could could we do the work
session on the 17th instead
um well we could we could do a committee
meeting work session on the 17th
although
um representative Creighton would not be
able to attend that
checking what's on my flight gets in
well the the thing is that um so we have
members of our committee who have been
placed on the Des rules update
subcommittee for our our
and they are planning on meeting on the
24th that's that's the issue so
um
we can I mean the rules committee
subcommittee is here
we can move that if you would I mean I'm
just looking for a sense of who's on
that
committee we can move that to if we need
to
how long
uh may I um how long so the the people
who are on the Des rules update
subcommittee is representative Creighton
representative Murray representative
Potenza representative Haskins
representative germana and
representative Davis
for the rules
you guys can decide when you're going to
meet
ma'am I get I I can do a 17th if we want
to do the 17th for the discussion and
the 24th for exact and rules we're gonna
that'll be fine yeah
all right
hello
October 17th October 17th
excuse me
so 17th would be further discussion
and presentation of the four I think
whatever how many other amendments for
discussion and then the 24th would be
the rules subcommittee and then an exec
session
uh we'll look at the Times
okay
all right thank you for discussing the
scheduling
and represent Bixby yeah um so if we're
moving moving on to a different topic uh
if that's available if we can do that
right now
um I just wanted to mention that um I
have put in a bill that will
uh provide for a position and a half in
the Department of Agriculture for
Organic certification uh because the
um the commissioner is concerned that uh
the
um the current the current way that
things are set up is likely to
um cause a loss of certification in
through in the department uh and we had
a there was a listening session uh with
New Hampshire nofa
organic Farmers Association uh last
night and I was extremely impressed with
how strongly the uh the organic farmers
want our Department of Agriculture to
maintain that certification program and
not be not have to go to other sources
for that
um there was a just a a real strong
sense of support for how well our
department is currently doing that and
the fact that our department is highly
accessible and they are very uh you know
having that New Hampshire seal of uh
certification is something that means a
lot to them in terms of both pride and
marketing uh so
um that's something that so if you have
constituents who are organic farmers uh
they may be getting in touch with you
let them know that that bill is in
process and that uh providing their
support for that bill is a way to to
help keep
um
keep
the certification in the state
representative
thank you madam chair representative
Bixby I was not able to attend the
meeting they said they were going to
record that is that on their website
uh I don't know if it's up yet but they
are going to have that available on
their website that it will be on the New
Hampshire nofa website
okay
all right one other thing I wanted to
um
cover with you guys is
the house leadership is putting together
an effort for each committee
to look at
administrative rules
in conjunction with and this is going to
be a huge undertaking it's probably
going to not just take our term but
maybe spill into other terms
um to look at administrative rules for
the agencies that we deal with Excuse me
to make sure that what the
statutes require and what the rules
require or request are
um
are one in the same and not and not and
that the agencies are not overstepping
their
Authority or bounds or whatever in the
rules that they've have put forward so
there's going to be an effort for um
they've requested three people from each
committee to take a look at and go
through
um the rules for the agencies that we
deal with and I have suggested from this
committee
um and this rules subcommittee would be
reporting to gel car
um I have requested from this committee
representative datsey representative
Haskins and representative Davis to be
included in that effort
and uh I am still waiting for the
parameters and guidance and everything
else from house leadership
um as to how they want to proceed with
this they just needed the names of three
people
to participate so just so that you know
where this is uh like I said I'm still
waiting for the guidance from house
leadership on how we'll proceed with
this subcommittee
question
oh
um
okay I can put your name into and
all right
uh some of you are also involved in
other subcommittees I know that we have
some people who are representative Davis
and representative Brouillard who is on
the epr study committee who else from
this committee anybody
involved in that no okay
um who else is on that committee that
study committee
is uh
partial
um representative partial I think
Lucian parcels and
and
um I think representative or senator
alsoehler's in it
yeah
um and I think I think there's one other
person no there's only four okay
all right
um
anyway uh the other thing I wanted to
make sure that you were aware I know I
sent out the email with the report from
the
oh New Hampshire
Department of Agriculture markets and
food we had the division of accounting
services or actually a review and
Reporting requirements for dedicated
funds and I just wanted to know if you
all received it and just so that you can
take a look and see uh you know what the
revenues were and what the expenditures
were and so forth and it's good good
information to know what dam is doing
the other thing I wanted to point out to
you was and there was a notice in the
house calendar
that the Big E is coming up
and um
commissioner Jasper
I guess it's not in this one it's the
new one commissioner Jasper had put out
a notice which I sponsored in the house
calendar saying that house members
each may get two free tickets to the Big
E for this year
all you have to do is contact the
Department of Agriculture secretary over
there in the Annex Building and request
two tickets and you got them
so um
I hope that you'll Avail yourself of
that opportunity because the Big E is
fun
it's the Eastern Expeditions
um
and it's held down in Springfield
Massachusetts
huge and it has five New England states
um
Rhode Island Massachusetts Connecticut
New Hampshire and Maine
that are they have their own buildings
and all kinds of uh competitions and so
forth so
um
don't know off the top of my head
but it's it's all listed in the uh in
the in the latest House calendar there's
a notice
so if you look in there you'll get all
the information you need
anything else that anybody has for the
good of the company committee
might be the person who knows more than
I do
which is
um on the non-amitable species
study committee
do we has that been action do we have a
third house member yet
you may I think you represent Bixby um I
spoke with Madam chair and uh she had
put represent coulon's name into the
speaker I don't believe you received any
confirmation of that yet
I will go to the speaker's office after
this meeting and make sure that
something is done
thank you
representative germano
thank you madam chair I just want to
inform the chair in the committee that
I've also been serving on the unlimited
service area access the out-of-state
trash uh special or study committee
rather uh and we are meeting again this
week we are going to be hearing from the
Attorney General's office regarding the
specifics about the interstate commerce
clause and uh how it limits us perhaps
uh and also a representative from the
municipally owned landfill in Mount
carvery so we're we're hearing from a
variety of groups and uh I am cautiously
optimistic that we will have some
legislation coming out of the study
group uh by November you'll be talking
trash huh
all right
thank you
um yeah any information you have from
any of that is always helpful as I serve
on this Solid Waste working group so
um good to know especially also the
folks who are serving on the epr study
committee anything that I can bring to
the solid waste working group at our
monthly meeting which meets at the end
of the month is always very informative
and helpful
anything else from the committee
I want to thank you very much for your
time and attentive
attentiveness and our Lively discussions
today uh I appreciate seeing you all
again and I look forward to seeing you
again on October 24th uh
for the democracies for the Democrats on
the committee please uh stick around so
we can have a little bit of a discussion